most multi-cloud management solutions
barely managed to manage and by 2021
less than half of businesses will be
effectively managing the number of
environments they run with IBM cloud you
can find the perfect balance between the
need to expand and the necessity to keep
control our management tools allow you
to better govern your cloud services by
increasing visibility and control of
your clouds through an integrated
approach with openness at their core our
tools and services integrate more easily
with your established environments to
create a common management solution
while orchestration adds a layer of
automation that enable services of all
types from different vendors to be
monitored managed and secured with IBM
cloud you have the tools to stop merely
managing and start achieving
[Music]
you